[Música]
a minha filha tinha apenas 14 anos
quando saiu do armário e se assumiu na
verdade eu já sabia e eu perguntei pra
ela e ela muito inquieto e perguntei
filha está apaixonada e ela respondeu
ela vicky
mal deu tempo de respirar e eu perguntei
para ela e ela também está apaixonada
por ti que naquele momento era tudo o
que eu queria saber se ela era
correspondida por que ninguém nos ensina
como pensar na descoberta de quem se é
dos nossos filhos não existe uma escola
de pais que nos prepara para lidar com
isso
e na verdade aquilo que ela vinha
afirmando naquele momento já era muito
claro para mim que o que ela precisava
ela precisava como qualquer outra
criança precisa que seu pai sua mãe seja
uma ponte para que essa criança possa se
desenvolver plenamente esse é quem ela é
a única coisa que eu lembro de pensar
nesse momento foi eu preciso ser muito
forte porque a minha filha vai precisar
muito de mim porque na verdade para a
sociedade
a culpa sempre a da mãe da criança
marlon vai mal na escola só tem
problemas para fazer amigos
a culpa é sempre da mãe essa criança não
come legumes não gosta de tomar banho de
mar tem depressão a culpa é sempre da
mãe mas na guiné ea gente tem que pensar
que essas crianças elas estão aí por
todos os lugares é ea mãe tem esse papel
de fazer o que já acolher e mostrar que
a vida pode ser de outro jeito
apesar da gente ter todas as copas do
mundo nos nossos ombros
passado um tempo
ela trouxe uma situação diferente assim
a gente mudou para a bahia em função do
meu trabalho e um lugar incrível mas num
paraíso numa praia para criar uma
criança de quatro anos e nesse lugar
vivian a gente tiver uma vila de
pescadores ea gente vivia entre pessoas
desta comunidade e pessoas que tinham
mudado para trabalhar e tinha um grupo
de umas dez crianças mais ou menos a
maioria de meninos e aí um dia flora
chega em casa muito furiosa assim nosso
bravo resmungando e eu perguntei filho
que aconteceu e ela me perguntou quando
é que eu vou virar um menino que me
causou estranheza mas saiu imediatamente
perguntei filha porque tu quer virar um
menino há os meninos podem tudo eles
sobem nas árvores
eles andam sem camisa eles mandam umas
brincadeiras né e aí eu pensei a minha
filha tinha só quatro anos quando se
desligou do machismo estrutural tão
presente na nossa vida e eu que não
sabia nada desse universo ainda na
intuição de mãe disse não tem nenhum
problema de você menina e subir nas
árvores e até mesmo mandar nas
brincadeiras
passado um tempo a gente mudou para o
rio de janeiro
e aí afora começou a desenvolver os
medos noturnos
ela tinha pânico para dormir todos os
dias acordava no meio da noite e vinha
pra nossa cama eu resolvi buscar ajuda
foi então que eu pedir indicação de uma
psicóloga na escola e aí a gente levou a
flora para terapia aos 11 aos nove anos
de idade
um dia essa psicóloga me chamou para
dizer manhãzinha que aflora precisa é um
contato maior com a feminilidade
ela precisa de uma presença mais
feminina
na verdade hoje em dia eu sei que o que
ela fez comigo foi um absurdo porque ela
jogou as descobertas sobre a sexualidade
da minha filha
no meu colo porque a culpa é sempre da
mãe teria sido muito mais simples se ela
tivesse me orientado e conversado comigo
sobre aquilo mas ela não fez isso e eu
sofri me culpei na verdade a sexualidade
ea flora entre os nove e 12 anos ela
acompanha puberdade
uma criança não tem noção da sua
sexualidade ela não sabe o que é sexo
ainda então quando o menino é chamado de
na sala de aula aos 67 anos ele
não sabe que aquilo mas aquilo é uma
violência na sua vida e ele cresce
sozinho infeliz foi fazer amigos
a gente não pode mais permitir que as
crianças passem por esse tipo de
situação
as crianças lgbt existem e precisam de
carinho cuidado e afeto como qualquer
outra criança
passado mais um tempo na adolescência da
minha filha ela uma amiga com os 16 anos
que já namorava uma menina foi colocada
para fora de casa pela sua família
e naquele momento eu só conseguia pensar
quando que essa menina virou um monstro
pra sua família
ela virou um monstro por demonstrar
afeto por outra menina mas que o
problema que existe nisso né nós
enquanto pais e mães que a gente quer
que os nossos filhos sejam felizes
intensos plenos do jeito que quiserem
esse é o nosso papel e essa história
dessa menina foi um dead line na mudança
mais radical da minha vida ea partir
desse caso eu fui buscar informações
eu fui buscar sites filmes paper livros
eu fui buscar informação para ajudar a
lidar com isso porque pra mim o que
fazia sentido era ter que conversar com
outros pais e outras mães e dizer que
isso não era um problema e assim eu
encontrei um grupo incrível de mulheres
mulheres mães de lgbt
e nesse grupo e descobriu que é empatia
sonoridade e empoderamento e aprendi que
a diversidade não é um problema
a cultura do preconceito é tão presente
na vida da gente que às vezes a gente
nem percebe os impactos negativos na
vida dessas crianças são uma coisa
assustadora 39,6 por cento dos
estudantes homens não gostaria de ter um
colega lgbt na sala de aula 35,2 por
cento dos pais e mães não gostaria que
seu filho tivesse um colega de escola
lgbt 60% dos professores não se sente
suficientemente informado para lidar com
essas questões em sala de aula
mas e aí e as crianças elas estão nesse
ambiente escolar e até quando a escola
que tem um papel tão importante da
formação dessas crianças e jovens vai se
comportar dessa maneira as crianças
trans
já pensou sobre isso eu vou contar uma
história nasceu o menino não temos um
menino trans
ele nasceu biologicamente menina mas
desde a sua terra infância e se
identifica como o menino à mãe dele
acolheu apoiou foi atrás de terapia foi
buscar ajuda nesse processo porque é um
processo e aí ela começou a estranhar o
comportamento dele
ele chegava em casa todos os dias na
hora do almoço é correndo para o
banheiro 17 6 na escola chegou aqui
correr todos os dias chega correndo para
o banheiro e aí na escola descobriu
conversando com ele que a escola não
proporcionou nenhum banheiro então das
sete e meia da manhã até a hora do
almoço essa criança não foi ao banheiro
ela desenvolveu vários problemas de
saúde na adolescência teve síndrome do
pânico porque a escola
não foi um ambiente acolhedor então a
gente precisa falar sobre isso porque a
escola precisa identificar as crianças
que sofrem
a escola tem um papel fundamental na
vida delas e são inúmeras as histórias
que a gente escuta dessas mães sobre que
seus filhos e filhas passaram na escola
então a gente não pode permitir mais que
a cultura do preconceito seja perpetuado
dessa forma a gente precisa combater o
preconceito sim mas com informação com
afeto com amor porque essas crianças são
como qualquer outras crianças
e se fosse o seu filho ao longo do tempo
as pessoas lgbts sofrem da violência
física e psicológica negação de direitos
escola família ambiente profissional
inúmeras consequências negativas disso
uma pesquisa recente registra que a
rejeição é responsável por problemas
sérios de saúde mental e comportamental
mas também que o acolhimento dos pais
muda completamente a vida dessas
crianças
essas crianças precisam sentir inseridas
numa família no ambiente escolar
saudável para que possam se expressar
só isso não falar de gênero sexualidade
inclusão é perder oportunidade de formar
pessoas mais justas mas iguais escutar e
compreender outras pessoas que pensam
diferente pode ser uma transformação na
sua vida quando a gente se conecta com
as pessoas
a gente passa a compreender as coisas de
outra forma
eu nunca imaginei uma ativista dos
direitos humanos
e eu tenho certeza que vocês assim como
eu não imaginavam esse tipo essas
situações que eu falei aqui porque elas
não faziam parte da sua vida à minha
filha só tinha 14 anos quando descobriu
o espanhol é apaixonada desejando ser
correspondida
como qualquer outro adolescente e eu
quando ela tinha 14 anos descobri muito
mais de quem eu sou e sobre esse mundo e
sobre essas crianças lgbts
elas existem estão em todas as escolas
estão nas famílias e na sociedade
querendo brincar de fazer amigos como
qualquer outra criança
nosso silêncio só mantém ela sem
sofrimento invisíveis sozinhas
nós somos o escudo dos nossos filhos
dialogue entendo também se liberta e do
preconceito sejam livres para acolher e
amar seus filhos independente de serem
lgbt ou não as crianças lgbt existem eu
tive uma talvez você nunca tenha parado
para pensar sobre tudo isso
eu entendo eu também não tinha mas eu
aprendi que o único problema em ser mãe
de lgbt é o problema é que alguns têm
com isso
obrigada
[Aplausos]